(hiphop music)
♪ Okay it's Tee ♪
♪ With Gary Vee ♪
♪ Sipping in safee ♪
♪ I know patience is the key ♪
♪ Putting out all my shit for free ♪
♪ This is Tea ♪
♪ With Gary Vee ♪
♪ Might go make a flip ♪
♪ Take your bitch ♪
- Good morning everyone.
Just finishing writing up
today's morning text.
And I'll be right with you.
I'll finish it later.
I don't wanna make you sit through it.
Morning, Morning Morning.
Morning to Tea with Gary Vee
we are starting to get towards mid May.
And we're in it.
Good morning everybody
on, let's see Twitter,
Facebook, YouTube, Twitch.
Great to see all of you this morning.
But shout out to Bax, Brian and body.
Scott Paschal we see
Ashwin, good to see you.
Flip daddy babes what's good.
What's up Tesha, Satella
bean, what's what's what's up,
Andy, Ess, Kj Delmar, Hunter Bean,
and all of my other friends.
Please take a screenshot of
this and share to the URL
that you have in your browser right now.
And get your homies and
your friends on here Destin.
Good morning.
How's your weekend?
- Excellent.
- Like Bill and Ted's.
- Exactly.
I've watched that in a long time actually.
- They made a new one right
and didn't do super well,
- Oh, I thought it was just
in like a talks of a new one.
But I don't know.
I don't remember.
- Yeah, me neither.
All right.
Let's get in the show.
- Cool.
- Hello.
- Good morning.
What's your name?
- Adaleta.
- Adaleta, nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you too, Gary.
How's it going?
- Super well.
Thanks for asking.
- Good.
- What's cooking?
- Yeah, nothing.
I'm over here.
It's 6 a.m. my time I'm on the west coast.
So I have my coffee next to me.
And I wanna talk today a
little bit about Tik Tok.
So I know you're obviously on there.
I am also active on there.
I was pretty quick to jump on it
because I saw an opportunity
and I wanted to be kind
of ahead of the curve.
So let's talk about
the strategy behind it.
I'm past the point of
should I be on there?
What is the best strategy
on actually being there?
How many times should you post today?
What kind of content?
Do you find a niche?
How long should the video be?
Those are the types of questions,
I have more about strategy
versus should I get on Tik Tok?
- So early things I'm seeing is one.
There doesn't seem to be at this point,
any disadvantage at posting
as often as possible.
You see some people posting
as many as 10 times a day.
And reaping the benefits.
So, times a day, I like to throw out three
and four 'cause I think
it's truly manageable.
If you're fully ambitious,
and all the way there
and you're over the mental
hurdle of worrying about likes,
and do you have anything to just say.
As far as what to put out,
I always think that the right strategy
is putting out
what you want versus what
you think is working.
So when I got on Instagram,
what was working was
incredible photography.
Instagram was a photography.
And my main business
and mindset content,
and it took a little while,
but it really then kind of kicked in.
And so if you look at Twitter,
if you look at Myspace, Myspace was music,
hardcore music.
And then Tila Tequila and Dane Cook
and others could win on that platform.
comedians, models, things of that nature.
So as far as what to put out,
I think that you need to put out
what you wanna be talking about,
however, being thoughtful
about copy overlay,
what song to use in the background,
using the hashtag for your paid,
for you page, fyp, things like that.
So there are tactics within it.
But if you wanna talk about, hiking,
I don't think you should
go and start twerking.
Do you know what I mean?
So and then there's duets,
and reaction videos.
There's subtle tactics
within the platform.
There's the ability to DM
and reach out to do collaborations.
There's the ability to
use your Instagram stories
and your Instagram feed
and your Twitter account
to build awareness
towards your Tik Tok.
So it's a lot of strategies
underneath there.
- Have you seen a shift
of the people who follow
on other platforms go to Tik
Tok or brand new audience?
I feel like they're a lot
younger from my perspective,
my normal demographic would
be women who are 25 to 45.
And Tik Tok,
you've got like the 14 year olds
who think they've got
life all figured out.
So have you seen kind
of that younger shift?
- Yeah, I think the
platform skews younger,
but I think over the last six months,
it's gotten dramatically older.
And I think within a year,
it becomes kind of
omnipresent from six to 45,
meaning everybody's kind of on it.
And then it just kind of
goes back to my point always,
which is poems destined
to be a major platform
and sticks around for three years in
that three years of its heat moment,
it will hit every demo,
except kind of 50 to older
and then you need another kind of three
to five years to go 50 and older,
like we've seen with Facebook,
and like you've seen with Instagram,
so that's kind of where I
think it's at right now.
- So trajectory,
do you think Tik Tok will be around
for a little bit longer,
when you mentioned Myspace,
that was kind of the first
social media I was ever on.
So it's interesting, obviously,
that's not really used as much anymore.
So do you see trajectory
of, longer lifespan?
- I think platforms are like TV shows,
some shows are destined to
be hot for 24 months, Vine,
TV shows Empire.
Other shows are destined
for 15, 20 year runs.
The Simpsons, Facebook,
so I'm not crippled
by that because whatever audience
you're able to build on Tik Tok.
You're able to build
awareness in that platform.
And then when Jigjaw comes
out and we all go there,
when you go over there,
a certain percentage
of your Tik Tok audience comes along.
If I hadn't built everything
that I've built in other platforms,
there's no way I'm at 3.5
million followers on Tik Tok.
So I think too many people
worry about, is this a fad?
That's what the people told
me about the internet in 1996.
When I launch mylibrary.com.
It's not about fads.
It's about when something's
on fire, you play it.
And then when it's not,
it's not when a club is hot.
You go there when it peters out,
you go to the next hot club.
When a restaurant is fucking the shit.
You go and eat there.
And when it's not, you don't.
And for some reason on social networks,
people are so audacious
about wasting their time,
without realizing what
they should be doing
is marketing on the platform
and extracting brand value.
- Absolutely.
I love it.
Thank you so much.
- You're welcome, take care.
Yep.
- Hey Gary,
How are ya?
- Hey Taz.
How are you?
- Yeah, not bad, how's your weekend?
- Very nice.
How's yours?
- Awesome.
Yeah, not pretty good.
It's currently 11 o'clock
here in Australia.
But so yeah, I'm a full
time wedding filmmaker,
my younger brother and I
own a wedding film business.
And we've been doing that for
about three or four years now.
I've recently actually decided
to start a personal brand
around creating free content
on teaching wedding films,
and actually just started a Tik Tok,
probably about a week ago.
You can get at me for not doing it sooner,
but just doing like where
Friesen wedding tips
for brides.
And so I was telling
my mom about this idea.
And by the way, like my mom's awesome,
both my parents always
supporting everything I'll do.
But she brought the point
that if I'm sharing our tips and tricks,
wouldn't that essentially
create more competition
for ourselves?
But that's not really my question.
My question was because
you just got me thinking.
How exactly do we
distinguish between opinions
and like actual advice?
- It's a really good question.
So I think it comes
down to a couple things.
One.
I always judge the person
that is giving the opinion
or the advice.
So how many big businesses
has your mom built?
- Zero.
- That's a good starting point.
To your point, she's fantastic.
And she's so supportive.
And I think her opinion,
slash advice on this issue has validity.
There is a lot of common
sense to the notion
that if you're giving away your secrets,
are you putting yourself
in a vulnerable spot?
The reality is my opinion after 22 years
of doing business professionally
and longer intuitively as a
kid is the world is abundant,
and winners win.
And I think the way the
internet works with branding,
I actually think you gain business.
I've lived that life.
There's plenty people I've taken my advice
and packaged it up and sold
it against my own fan base.
And I've been able to extract money
out of my fan base by
repackaging what I do for free.
And it's silly to watch,
and I laugh at it,
but I don't think it's come at my expense.
So I think my biggest
barometer between opinion
and advice is first advice is opinion
and opinion is advice.
And--
- Of course, yeah.
- What I spent all my time on
is judging the person who delivered it.
And then even when somebody,
even when Jeff Bezos
would give me advice, I would say, okay,
but he's coming from the perspective
of how Amazon was built.
And I think
that could be the case or
if I paid attention to him,
one of the things
that I spent a lot of time
on is not giving advice,
or opinions or thoughts or
hyperbole around how it happened
for me, for me, it's
more about observations,
not what happened with me.
Obviously, there's some things
that have happened with me.
And so that's kind of,
that;s kind of how I see it.
'Cause I guess,
obviously,
being in a position where
I'm obviously still learning.
And maybe I can't judge,
maybe I can't accurately judge
whether they know what
they're talking about or not.
So obviously with you,
I know a lot about you.
I've been following you
for a few years now.
And so I trust and I know you say,
you shouldn't always
trust even your opinion
but or your advice, but obviously,
I know that your comments
are gonna have more weight
or more validity behind
someone, Joe down the street.
So I guess it's just that coming from
that position of judging whether they have
that validity or not.
- Which ultimately led me
to not listening to anybody,
but valuing the experience over opinion.
- Yes.
- And not being fearful of being wrong.
- Yep.
Sounds pretty simple.
- All of its simple.
We make it complicated.
- Yes, I think we overthink
things a lot of the time.
Agreed, okay mate, thank you.
- Awesome.
Cheers Gary.
Thanks, bye.
- Hey, Dustin.
- Yeah.
- Am I not coming in good?
It's just some people--
- It's a little on the quiet side.
I just heard your mom
laugh though (snickers)
- Fair enough, hold on.
- Test.
- Yeah, hold on one second.
What about now?
- It's better.
- Can you hear me?
- Yeah.
- Let's rock and roll.
- Cool.
- Daniel, what's good,
- What's up?
How we doing?
- Good.
- I'm super nervous today, fuck.
I just wanted to say thank you so--
- Where you from?
- I'm from Australia as
well, from Melbourne.
So it's night time here.
It seems to be a--
- Nice, back-to-back Aussies.
- It's a day for Australians.
I just wanna say thank you so much
for this opportunity,
this has been a journey
and, really looking
forward to talking to you.
I'm a bit nervous as well.
So what I wanted to start
with was a little bit
about my background just
to lead up to my question.
So basically when I
was like six years old,
my grandmother passed
away who was very close
with and similar to you,
I come from like half
Russian and polish background
on my mum's side and Italian on my dad.
So I experienced loss at a very early age.
When I was 10.
My mum was diagnosed with cancer
and she got sick and then when
I was 16, she passed away.
So I went through quite a
lot of stuff in my life.
And after I finished high school here
when I was 18, I really
struggled like mentally.
It was hard to finish school.
I went through a lot of depression,
I went through all sorts of challenges
and suicidal thoughts
and that kind of stuff.
And I really went through like
the dark night of the soul.
And so at about 25, I started
to sort of come out of that.
And here I am today and I'm doing good.
And I wanna help people.
I've been through a lot of stuff.
I've put a lot of work on myself.
I've done a lot of
things to improve myself.
So I want to give you that backdrop.
So the question I have for you is,
despite having followed you for a while,
and also all this investment
I've done into myself,
I feel like I'm still operating at 40
or 50% of my potential.
And I sabotage myself,
I hold myself back.
And I know that what I have to say
and what I wanna give
to people is so valuable,
but yet there's a part of me
that's conflicting, I
value myself at times
and then I don't value myself
and then I'm fearful of
trying to sell myself.
Similar to Daniel from Friday, like that.
I know so much
that I have good intention,
I'm coming from a hard space,
but--
- What are you trying to sell?
- At this point, that's the thing.
So I used to be a personal trainer
and I studied also holistic health.
So I wanna get into the
speaking realm and world.
And what I'm thinking of doing now
is I already have a brand
name for the business,
which is head body.
But at the moment, I'm
working on the personal brand,
which is obviously my name.
And I wanna combine sort
of the, how to help people
in their life with all
the holistic aspects.
So not just the mental
side, but the nutrition
and the diet and all that
other stuff, hydration
and your thoughts because
they all play a role.
So I want to combine both worlds.
But I it's kind of funny 'cause,
I was originally asked to
be on the show on Thursday.
And so it was like last minute type thing
and I felt you were Jedi Mind fucking me
because I just heard your voice
put out more content,
put out more content.
So Friday, I didn't get on
and it's just been like
have had these extra days.
So I've been really trying
to put out as much content
as I can.
- What have you noticed
in those four days?
- In terms of what, particularly?
- Anything, because the reality
is there's so many
people that wanna speak,
wanna coach, wanna build a personal brand.
And the problem is to
be successful in that,
you need leverage.
You need people to give a fuck.
And the way to get people to give a fuck
is to put out ungodly
amounts of content for free
and to speak for free before
people are willing to pay you.
Because what you're
doing is building brand.
Most people confuse sales
and branding and marketing.
And so there is no shortcut
to building a brand.
Nike almost went out
of business seven years
into its company, and
people are wildly confused.
There's 4 billion Gary Vaynerchuk's
and Daniel Elle's.
And so, I get it,
everybody feels like they
have something to say.
I mean that Daniel, every
single person actually
feels they have something to say.
The separation is the execution.
- I actually was thinking about that too.
And I'm thinking about actually
wanting to ask you that
'cause I literally put
one of the questions,
I sent in to you guys was exactly that.
How do I get people to give a fuck enough
to hear what I have to say?
How do you earn the trust--
- By putting out your best treats.
By being honest by talking
about things you know.
By telling stories, by communicating.
On this page that I have here.
That's what I'm doing them on.
I don't ask for anything.
I don't have any products
at the moment to sell.
I'm just giving everything I know.
- The biggest issue I see in the market
is a lot of people start
something, they hear me
then they realize I'm not gonna give,
I'm gonna give away for free
but in the back of their mind,
they know that they're going in
for the sale at some point
and that polar push really is a struggle.
it's a struggle.
I think that a lot of, to me,
the best way to eventually
start a business
is once the demands there,
a lot of people try to create the demand,
but subconsciously,
not even consciously, subconsciously
they're building only towards
eventually having the product.
They focus on things like the name
of the company, like you do.
The name doesn't mean
anything, literally zero,
the name of your company, and
brand actually means zero.
The ability to build it is everything.
Names are made, the fuck
does Google mean or Nike?
Or Beats by Dre?
Or Under Armour or Champion?
Or Sprayground?
Adidas, none these
fucking things mean dick.
Nobody gives a fuck, Coca-Cola.
They were made, names don't matter.
- It's true, it's very true.
My name is Gary Vaynerchuk
if I was built, I made it.
Not like my name is not
Johnny fucking wonderful.
You know what I mean?
People are just super confused by that.
They spend time on the name.
They, you and i don't i don't judge this,
I have empathy for this.
You're thinking about what product
and service are you eventually gonna sell,
again conscious or not,
You're building money.
I get it.
One of the great advantages
I have is I don't have a framework
that monetizes my audience.
- Like when you're not Gary Vee,
and you don't need to
monetize your audience,
and it's not, I'm not trying
to monetize my audience
in the sense of like maliciousness or--
- I agree, I agree.
- I don't wanna work.
Like I was washing dishes for
my dad, shout out to my dad
but I was I was washing
dishes for my dad, doing a job
that really made me
miserable prior to COVID
and so I don't want to do that job
that you always say,
go do that shitty job so
you can build this thing.
Is that possible though to do that?
Can I?
- Of course it's possible
but you have to understand supply
and demand, there are literally right now,
15 to 100 million people,
trying to do the same
exact thing as you are.
So when I tell people to tell their story
and to stay in their lane,
their only way to win is
to make it super personal.
The only reason I break through
and others break through is it's my truth.
People can follow me and make quote cards
and put on our Instagram
and I can why this Gary Vee fucking win.
He's just saying the
same motivational thing.
No, I'm not.
I'm saying my thing.
My truth, my actual truth.
So I think you need to, your breakthrough
is your actual truth.
- Well, it's your funny you
said that, with Tik Tok.
I started Tik Tok.
And I noticed I was
like, I put out a video
and it just was one of
the trends and I was like,
I felt so shit about it.
I was like, "This isn't me."
This is what's trending.
and what's gonna get hits and it didn't,
and it probably didn't
'cause my feeling was like--
- Correct.
So I actually put out a video today
which was so much more my truth
and I was like I felt so good about it.
And I didn't care as much
about how many followers
or how many views I got,
'cause it just felt real.
Like--
- Brother, do you know in the early years.
My favorite part of not having anybody
watch it was knowing one day
everybody would watch it.
- How do you get to that?
That's the thing I struggle with.
because I'm good at what I do.
You have to have a sense
of like, do you think,
I'm good at being fully me?
I'm good at telling my shit.
To your point.
- So what do you think it's
gonna take them for me not to--
- I think it's gonna
take you telling stories
about the darkness about that loss,
about where you were about things
you've seen, things you
learned washing dishes,
things you learn, just
stories true stories.
True Stories, true stories.
- (mumbles) Already,
just put that out there.
It seems like a strength for me
but sometimes it can be a weakness I feel
but I'm very open with with my stuff
because I want it to come
from a place where it's
not like me, me, me,
it's more like I get you like
I want to relate to people,
and then help guide them
through their own stuff
based on what I've also experienced.
I totally understand.
And I think the way you do that
is volume across the board,
volume across the board, be everywhere.
To me, I'm actually on a mission.
And I think a lot of people
are like a half pregnant mission.
I'm genuinely on that same
mission, bro, generally.
- What are you talking about with death
and stuff I think about
all the time, and legacy
and what I want to be known for
my life, my whole life's purpose,
if I'm gonna go through
all this loss and stuff.
you had Eric Thomas on DailyVee.
I think or one of those
one of the shows, you got.
And he says something like,
you've gotta go through all this pain,
get something out of your pain.
So it's like, I feel like--
- Daniel, how old are you?
- I'm gonna I'm actually this
is early birthday present.
I'm turning 31 on Sunday.
- Happy birthday, Bro.
Bro.
When I turned 30 I've made at,
that point in my life I'd
made zero, zero content
for the internet in my entire life.
- I just started my career so (chuckles).
- Good, definitely realize
we're just in the beginning
definitely realize that.
- So let me ask you do you think,
given what we just spoke about,
I can't...
If I don't wanna do those shitty jobs,
are you telling me that I have
to just do this shitty job
so that I can avoid monetizing
or trying to create a product or--
- No I'm telling you that
if you try to monetize
and sell to your audience
when you don't have one,
it's not gonna go well.
- Sure.
(laughs)
- It's literally like going
into a mixed martial arts,
UFC match, never training.
- I see what you mean.
But I don't--
- Who the fuck's gonna buy from
you when you've done nothing
for them?
Motherfucker?
Do you know how many
fucking things I've done
for everybody in this audience
and they still haven't
signed up for Wine Text?
And that's we're all month.
- We call you Wines Tex in Australia.
- I know, brother I know.
But do you know what I mean, Daniel?
Trying to get your audience to convert
is very, very, very difficult.
And most people,
- (mumbles)
there's only two ways to do it my way,
which is build a brand for so goddamn long
that you actually build
such a deep relationship
that most people
that most people get into a place
where they're almost guilted.
I feel like a lot of people are signing up
for Wine Techs right now
just because like damn,
why do I buy wine from somebody else?
Gary's brought me so much,
or the bizarro reverse version of me.
They fucking lie.
They fucking make people feel like shit.
There's like two ways to
have a good relationship
either build them up,
There's two ways to have a
long standing relationship.
One, you build a person up,
and you give them so much love
and you're building them up.
And because of that, you stay together.
Two, you actually tear them down
and make them so insecure,
they don't feel that they can leave.
It's on some Star Wars shit, bro.
Fine line between fucking
the dark side and Jedi's.
Is this fucking narrow.
The people that look like me on Instagram
that are making that money,
90% of them are putting their audience
in unhealthy relationships
that are selling them fear
and fucking bullshit.
- Yeah, agreed.
- I'm selling happiness, hope
and truth and practicality.
And the fine line in the
beginning is super close.
People think that me and
other people are the same.
And in 20 years they'll realize
we were completely fucking different.
- Yeah, hearing that from you
just churning something in me
because what you just said
about no one gives a fuck you I am
and no one knows who the fuck I am,
I've got like 80 followers,
just out of my page
few weeks ago or something,
on Instagram at least
and I've got the same handle
on Twitter and Tik Tok as well.
So I still feel a bit confused
about I totally understand
what you're saying
about not trying to monetize
because who the fuck am I?
I'm very humble.
I have no issue in accepting that--
- And the second you monetize every person
that comes starting to
person 200 on is going to see
that you're about that selling shit life.
And there's a million of fucking you.
When people stumble on me,
how many people in the
comments say me right now
in the comments,
were like we're waiting
for the other shoe to drop
for me to sell you my course
or my fucking off site
or my fucking island
or people take a long time like waiting,
Alright, this guy can't
be really doing this.
Like this guy.
Wait, he's just, he's just about to.
- It's like people wanna buy from you,
they literally, Garry when it went--
- No, no, no, I would
argue the other thing
that they couldn't believe,
why would I do this?
'Cause they didn't know me yet.
They know that my entire
business life was elsewhere.
- That's the thing too.
If my business life is
focused on this stuff,
and so then what do I literally--
- Patience.
- But what do I do?
- What do I do for money
if I don't wanna eat?
- I don't know.
But I don't know.
Here's the fun part of it.
It's fun to say I don't know,
because you don't want to do other things,
which is amazing.
But I'm gonna say it again,
some people don't wanna train
for 13 weeks after training
for 10 years for their first UFC fight
and they get their fucking ass beat.
Bro, you're gonna get your ass beat.
What's gonna happen?
You're gonna go in with that,
$49 product that $200 product and what?
Convert two people and then what?
- Exactly.
- Now you've fucking went
for the fucking kill.
Now what?
Now you've changed your
relationship and your brand,
which is okay.
Let me say this very clear
it is wildly okay to sell.
Who knows I might wake
up in four years be like,
fuck it.
I'm charging $10,000 a month
to be in Tea with Gary Vee.
Four days a week and
that's what I'm gonna do.
I don't give a fuck, everything's okay.
It's just sell something you believe in.
And also know when you go in for the ask
that if it doesn't convert, now
you don't have the leverage.
- Do you think I'll have more value
in myself 'cause I've always struggled
to sell even though
I've like always wanted
to genuinely sell like
when I was a trainer.
I always felt guilty
like, I'm robbing someone,
but at the same time valuing
that I can bring good--
- Daniel, it's because you
didn't believe in the product,
I promise you.
There's, bro.
How long have you followed me?
- A couple years.
- Good.
You know how many businesses I have?
But if I'm not promoting them,
I don't feel like it's
bringing the most value.
It's even the biggest
insight to Wine Techs.
I so know how good it is.
That's why I got loud.
I had five sneakers with K-Swiss,
I had different loudness with
them completely predicated.
The economics were the same,
completely predicated on
my own personal opinion
on if it was worth 90 bucks.
The reason so many people struggle to sell
is they don't believe in
what they're fucking selling.
And then you have a small group of people,
you have a small group of people
that make a lot of money quickly,
'cause they don't give
a fuck about anything.
They have no conscious,
and they sell everything
as if it's the best
but they're fucking dirt.
They're broken.
They're short term.
And then you have the small percent
the whole mass of the
middle of 90% right here.
Just completely lost,
just they don't believe
in what they're selling.
You got 5% over here who wins short term,
they have a good run
for five or seven years.
They're the ones that go bankrupt.
They're the ones who got
fucked up, drug problems,
like all sorts of shit.
They're the ones that just
sell on with no conscious.
They don't give a, they are so broken,
they can't care about you.
They don't care about themselves.
Then you have a small group
that I hang out with, the other 5%
that are in it for so long
that they build brands.
But I haven't even started,
every fucking person
on earth is gonna know who I am.
- How do you when you're ready
to make that switch from
giving, giving, giving
to them asking?
- When you genuinely can't breathe
without telling people
about something to buy.
Can't breath.
- So it has nothing to do
with the metrics of anything?
- (scoffs) Of course not.
That's the people that
win for five minutes.
What do you think I can
do to get more engagement
on things like Instagram and Facebook?
Like with postings--
- I'm not worrying about the engagement
by putting out your fucking truth?
I made wine videos on YouTube in 2006
when it was just pirated content.
Nobody gave a fuck but I gave a fuck.
I started making social
media content when 95%
of the world 98% of the world didn't know
what social media was.
Bro, it's a marathon.
Every question you've asked
is a short term question.
- No, no, I know.
- I know you know.
I think for you the formula
like if you were my best homie,
I'd be like, bro, you
have to find a side hustle
that maintains so that you
can go long on the thing
that you want to be.
You see where I'm going?
It's why I like flipping so much.
It teaches people how to market.
It teaches people that supply and demand.
- I think what you're talking about
Garrison's flipping, or?
- Just everything, retail
arbitrage go into it.
Discount store in Australia
and flipping it like,
I love that stuff.
So I got a bounce, dude, I love you.
- Can you follow me?
- I could, I'm happy to follow you.
- Can ask you one thing real quick.
When you come back to Melbourne,
can I potentially meet you?
Yes, hit up, Dustin.
- All right, thank you so much.
Really appreciate it.
- You got it.
- Thanks, Garry.
- Take care brother.
- Fuck, Dustin, send me that URL.
I typed it in wrong.
I found some lady in Alabama.
Let's keep going.
- Hello.
- I hope you can hear me
my Internet's going in
and out a little bit here.
- It's hanging in, what's your name?
- Norma.
- Norma?
- And I'm from Texas,
currently living in Saudi Arabia.
And I don't know if you remember
a couple of months back we
had a five minute FaceTime
but I was so nervous.
All I could do is thank
you for five minutes--
- I remember.
- Okay, so my kids told
me not to blow it today.
(laughs)
- I'm not joking.
It's been like a mom fail ever since then.
Yeah, I have three kids.
So it's been quite the weekend.
I have an Instagram account,
my story isn't finished.
And basically, I put little
blurbs every day positive,
or certain life lessons that
I put out there with humor.
I've had so many people
messaged me saying,
you could make you write a book
or put a book together or something.
So I was wondering
if I gathered all that
information, should I self publish?
Or how do you self publish
or should I blog more?
Because--
- Yap.
Why do you want to write a book?
- I've always written,
I had tons of journals
from when I was little,
I have a book of poems,
I have...
And this is what I go back to
when I'm trying to look for content.
When I'm putting it out
and I put things out
that are real.
Everything that I put out
has happened to me in
some way shape or form.
Mistakes, fun stuff, embarrassing stuff.
And because I'm in my 50s, I've
had all these life lessons.
And there's so many
things that have happened,
bad things too, that people
it doesn't define you.
When I put these out,
I'll get messages like wow, Norma,
you know what, maybe I
can do this after all.
Now I decided
for example last year to
enter the half Ironman
just out of the blue I decided okay,
I need to do this 'cause
it's been on my bucket list.
I did, not knowing how to
swim not knowing how to bike
and I ran 30 years ago
was the last time I ran.
I did it in eight hours and 11 minutes.
- Norma, Norma.
Why do you wanna write the book?
Let's go to the punch line
'cause it will help me give you the answer
that I have.
Which is why?
- Because I feel like I have
something to say that people--
- Right.
So, I got you.
So I want you to go to
this website called Google.
And--
- I know,
All my friends, who are in their 50s
and the grandmas in their 60s and 70s.
They don't understand that social media
and technology is a must.
And I blog about that,
or I talk about that
because you're not getting
(interference drowns out
conversation) age kid.
So you need to type,
How do I Self Publish?
What I would probably put in
is how do I self publish on Amazon?
Yep, and I think by this afternoon,
you'll know how.
- Which is easy.
I can do all that.
That's not a problem.
- And just like you figured
out the half Iron Man,
you'll do this
and the reason you want to write
is you have something
to say and away we go.
- Okay, now, Instagram
is where I've started
and I have a following.
How do I utilize all the technology
to get the bigger audience
or to get what I have to say out there?
And do I just focus on Instagram
and just start a little bit,
on all the other social media,
Like Tik Tok is, I love Tik Tok,
I'm like obsessed with it.
I will be consistent until
the day I die on this.
It is about putting out information.
Podcasts, YouTube,
Twitter, Tik Tok Snapchat,
it is forever and ever
going to be the answer.
- Twitter.
- People struggle with
not having an audience.
I preferred it.
Let me stay there
for a second 'cause it's
a super important point.
People don't go to other platforms,
most of everybody here isn't signing up
for Twitter right now,
or isn't going there
because it's hard to
amass an audience there.
Because they don't like the
feeling of what they think
is wasting their time by posting something
where nobody's listening.
- But had I not gone to Twitter,
I wouldn't be on your show right now,
'cause that's how I got on.
Even though I only have
100 whatever it is,
but Snapchat.
- Look, the punchline is
figure out which medium works
for your written word, audio, video,
and then 'cause much of it
as possible in as many places
that you possibly can do it
for as long as possible
and then pop up your head in three years
and see if that's giving you
the leverage to do the thing
that you theoretically
think you want to do.
The point I was making
earlier, but I preferred it is,
I like the process more
than the affirmation
and the accolades and the
successes that come along with it.
Until people figure that out.
They will continue to be insecure,
audacious, ego-led to why
they're not setting up accounts
in other places.
Once you set up those accounts and do it
for a long period of time you
build enough of an audience
that when you then tell them
you have a self published book,
it will convert.
- Okay, alright, so it's not,
I am trying to find my audience.
I have relatable content,
'cause I'm kind of,
or I feel like I have like
a smorgasbord of everything.
I had a strict childhood
because I had a mother
from another country,
so that was the first 30 years of my life.
And then it wasn't until I
moved away to Saudi Arabia,
that I was actually able to grow
because I didn't have to worry
about the judgment and stuff.
And so I get all those type followers.
And then I've got the older age group
and then I've got the moms,
why are you letting your kids listen
to Gary Vee because my kids are 13 and 14.
They don't understand that,
I'm like, if my kids
hadn't listened to you,
or if I hadn't listened to you,
then one of my kids wouldn't be doing
so well in school because
he absolutely hated school
because I was like school school school
because that's how I was raised.
And so to get past all
that, and of course, again,
this is what I write about or blog about
and people are just like,
yeah, you need to tell people more
and so, maybe I do have something
that is relatable
for people to wanna read
or listen to or what yeah,
I think the game is completely strictly
about you not overthinking it,
and you just executing like you did,
I think Iron Man is the comp.
I think you caught up
in what 99.9% of society
is caught up in right now
which is metrics of audience.
There's people who've written books
that had zero followers on social media
when the book came out, and
wrote best selling books.
George Lucas had zero fans
when he launched Star Wars.
- Yeah, it's not just, self publishing
to see my name out there.
It's self published or writing something
or blogging about something
that can truly make a
connection with somebody
'cause the ones that I've
had that have followed me,
they fuck with the journey.
- But, my point there Norma
is if that was actually the case,
you wouldn't be asking the question.
That was my case.
And guess what?
I never fucking asked anybody anything.
I never read anything about anything.
I never hit up anything about anything.
I fucking did it.
If that was the case,
you would just do it.
What time is it right now?
Over here, it's a 4:40 over here.
4:40 in the afternoon.
- Yes, yeah.
- You wouldn't be sitting in 4:40 p.m.
in Saudi Arabia asking this question.
You just be working on making more stuff.
- Yeah, and that's yeah.
Got it, got it.
- Got it.
- Yeah, I do.
- That's it.
Awesome.
Finally, you didn't blow it
this time, tell your kids.
- I will, they're watching now.
- Good see ya.
- Bye.
- Look, the Norma exchange
is super important.
People convincing themselves of things
that aren't true to fit
the narrative they want.
The formula super basic.
The more true you can go with (grunts)
excuse me with the content,
the more likely it has an
opportunity to hit somebody.
Because it's authentic,
you're now no longer selling vanilla.
The reason so many people lose
on Instagram, for example,
with motivational content is
'cause it's not their truth.
They just think it works
'cause they've seen four or
five other people hit with it.
And then you just got to
contextually distributed it
across all the platforms
that have the attention.
It's really simple.
There's what's stopping you is not simple.
It's grounded in childhood
it's grounded in so many variables,
environment, chemicals, DNA
but this game is simple.
Let's keep it going.
- Hello Gary.
- Hey brother.
- How you doing?
- This is fun surprise.
- Yeah you didn't know.
So initially I was gonna be on Friday
which was my 30th birthday.
But things obviously, thank you very much
context for people who are watching
is that I work for Gary
in VaynerMedia London
at VaynerMedia LDN on Instagram
you want to follow them
and I guess context for you.
So I've known for a couple of weeks
that I was going to be on
'cause I Zain as a cheeky birthday favor
and I know you've talked
a bunch even today
about sort of doing
things that your truth.
So a few months ago I
started a website aimed
at helping people get
hired by top companies
'cause it's something I
sort of felt I was good at
and obviously working for
you, ultimatetvtemplate.com.
The website still exists for those
who want to check it out.
But, I've been thinking about it a lot.
So that's not what the question
is about because I've pivoted.
So I've been into painting for
like five years on and off,
as you can see behind.
- Yes.
- Since lockdown began,
I've just become like freakishly obsessed.
- Crazy.
So I did Kung Fu for about 12 years,
I'm a black belt in Kung
Fu, and maybe bar alcohol,
this is the thing I find
myself most in love with
and I stopped drinking this year.
So I need a new hobby.
So and I've done a lot of
research in the build up for this
'cause I wanted to sort of have context
on what you think.
So I looked at every question about art
and stuff that you've
been asked historically.
And in 2016, you said there's
10s of thousands of artists
who will give up on their craft
and never make it who
would be millionaires
if they were your business partner.
So if we imagine this
was our first meeting
as your business partner
and you're giving me advice
for the next 10 years to build something,
what would your advice be?
- To give your art to
the most widely known
influencers on the platforms
that mattered the most.
I would make art, I would
post it on my Instagram,
everywhere, for that matter,
I would make a Tik Tok of me
making it and then I would give
that art upfront, to,
the Charlie Demmilio's,
the whoever they may be
your favorite footballer,
whoever, literally DMing
and you hit up 45 people,
580 players in the Premier
League, and one says yes.
And then that one person
doesn't even post it
on their Instagram or their story
and you're devastated 'cause
you finally got a yes.
And you do that over and over
and over until you have
your quote unquote, "Break."
What you have in real
life, 'cause you have me,
if your ability, what's
your Instagram handle?
- Aengus Boyle.
- So what's gonna happen now
is you're going to take
one of those photos,
literally, literally post
it on your Instagram,
right now after this call
because a bunch of people
are following you right now
and come up with some sort of price.
$313, 330 pounds.
- When D designs was on on
Friday and shit blew up for her,
I realized how big an
opportunity the show was
so I built a website over the weekend
and arbitrarily priced the art
so--
- What's your URL?
- artbyaengus.com
- Super smart.
Dustin, get on that real quick.
So yeah, very honestly,
your career's started right now.
Like here it is.
I think you need a lot of my fans
are American based on
this is wildly global.
Make sure you don't
get killed on shipping.
Luckily, is your art on paper.
Is that on canvas, how heavy is it?
- The bigger ones are all on canvas.
I made some super light ones on cardboard.
- Love it.
Look, I think this is how it works, bro.
Nice dude.
So Good.
(Aengus laughs)
This is amazing.
keep scrolling.
I thought you were painting
with your feet for a second.
I was about to go crazy.
Keep scrolling Dustin.
Yeah, see, honestly,
you're gonna sell these things right now.
It's just gonna happen.
And I think it's fucking amazing.
And do you ship everywhere?
- Yeah, I'll have to figure that out.
- Yeah, you have to figure that out.
Yeah brother I honestly
I think to be very frank
I think your career, the end
of your VaynerMedia career
and the beginning of your art career
might be happening
literally in this moment
and that makes me so fucking happy.
First of all you're really good.
I'm proud of you bro, it's really good.
Hit small or medium's fine.
Yeah, man.
I mean obviously you've got
a lot of good vibe stuff too,
which is gonna do well with my audience
and then, this is just how it is man,
if Jay Leno wasn't
pushed by his management,
he would have never been who he was.
Like some people
are the art and then
some people need a break.
Some people need a partner in crime,
somebody needs a cosign,
you have the luxury of
being great executive
at our company
that makes me desperately
try to get everybody
to buy a piece of your art right now.
And so you've built up
that leverage with somebody
who can give you that cosign.
There's a lot of people
right now who don't have me
or anything that looks
like me in the world.
So what they have to
do is kinda what I did.
My cosign in a lot of ways was DigNation.
It was Kevin Rose, and Alex Obrah,
who kinda gave me a shout out on DigNation
in like 2005, 2006 Internet,
and that kind of was my little spark.
And, it always happens.
It happens all the time.
And so, hopefully this is
the beginning of yours.
- Thank you so much.
I love you.
- I love you back then.
Take care.
Talk to you soon.
- All right.
- That was a fun surprise.
Good job, Dustin.
Good people.
Real good people.
Let's keep going.
- Hi, Gary, good morning?
- Good morning, brother.
How do you pronounce your name?
- Alain?
- Yeah, like straight line.
- I like that?
Yeah, very cool.
- How's quarantine going?
- Pretty well.
How about for you?
- I'm in Tucson, Arizona.
So I'm enjoying the heat
while being quarantine.
So it's been good.
- Good.
- I have two questions for
you related to each other.
but I want to start off by telling you
a little bit about about the project
that I have going on right now.
So I got into the real estate
industry to build spec houses.
And so that's been going well,
I built one and I sold the first house.
I financed that with the help of my dad.
He supported me and he lent me some money.
And I sold that one,
and now I'm on to the second house.
So that's been good.
But obviously I wanna get to the point
where I'm building 20 houses, 50 houses,
100 houses at a time,
and that will take time.
I've got patience, I've got time.
I'm in college.
I'm a 20 year old college student.
So I guess like my question
for you is, as a 20 year
old college student,
how do I go out there and find investors?
How do I go out there
and find cash
because I personally don't
have enough cash in the bank.
- Of course, by spending
no time convincing people.
So, to turn that--
- Want me to bring that down?
There's a 22% chance I
would give you money.
When I'm most liquid,
there's a zero percent chance
that 99% of people would give you money.
There's a whole group of people
that would actually give you money.
You need to figure it out.
Obviously, knock on wood.
Thank God,
you had a situation where your father
can help you a little bit.
So I'm sure it's running
through your mind.
Your dad probably runs in some
circles where you can go into
that world.
Do you even wanna go there?
How much do you want to
feel like you built this
on your own two feet?
Not with your dad.
That's always a tough
thing for 20 year old.
I struggled with going into my dad
even though I was going
to go into my dad business
to help him build his business.
I even struggled with that.
So I understand that.
But the only thing--
- I don't see that as a problem.
I guess I've always been
very close to my dad.
So--
- I'm sure your dad has, I'm
sure your dad has friends.
It all depends.
It all depends on your consciousness.
So for example,
I am not great at raising money
because I don't mind
losing every dollar I have.
But in my DNA,
I struggle with the idea of
losing other people's money.
So that's a shortcoming
of mine in some ways,
'cause it's led to me
leaving money on the table
where I could have raised capital.
The other thing is,
I think you map the 500
richest people in Arizona,
and do you go to Santa Clara?
- Yeah, go to Santa Clara.
I would Google,
most successful alumnis from
Santa Clara history, enter,
see the whole list, then
hit him up on LinkedIn
and Instagram.
The punchline is you just keep asking
until someone says yes, instead
of dwelling on the people
that are saying no,
I think you get as many
five minute conversations
as possible.
And the second you know that
the person's not interested,
or they're just, there's been meetings
that people taken because
somebody else cosign me,
and I wanted to have the meeting.
And literally I jumped out of the meeting
within five minutes 'cause I could realize
that the person was there
just because the other person asked them
and they weren't interested
and I wasn't interested
in wasting my time,
let alone there's.
- Okay, so basically just go out there
and hustle and reach as
many people as I can.
- An unconscious framework unconscious,
just completely unemotional,
unconscious robotic framework
of giving your best pitch
and having no feelings.
Goose egg zero fucking feelings.
When somebody's like, not interested.
You're too young.
I don't trust you.
A lot of kids ask me like,
how do I get people to respect me?
You don't.
You can't change the fact that you're 20
and you look 16.
That's not that's not changing.
And so I lived that life.
- Yes, Dustin.
35 looking like 16.
Your video's coming in a little choppy.
So I was just--
- Who, mine?
- Yeah, now it's better.
Once like I said, the
windows keep alternating,
it gets better.
But yeah, now you're good.
- Alain, I think it's about
zero emotion for the no.
Everybody, like 98% of
this audience right now
in the comment section.
All of their struggles comes
because they're emotional about the no.
And then they fucking try to
convince like Uncle Harry,
or fucking rich man Magoo in town.
why they're the right thing.
Don't convince the non convinceable.
- Is that Is that so I guess
that kind of covers my
second question for you.
Is that the same answer you would give me
as to how do I scale this
at this stage in my life?
- Scale is single handedly
your biggest vulnerability.
The addiction for scale in
the business world right now
has completely fucked everyone.
The amount of businesses
that are about to go out of
business in this next year,
'cause they overvalued scale
when they had something is remarkable.
Wine Techs.
Obviously, in a year
you'll be able to sign up
and I appreciate that,
I'm scaling it slowly.
The economics have to
work I can run ads crazy
to like get more users and scale
but the economics aren't there
and the vulnerability would become there.
And I'd rather be the fucking tortoise.
Alain.
- I'm telling you right now, bro.
Like, you need to figure out why.
Honestly, why do you wanna scale?
Your own insecurities
and wanna show everybody
you can do it by yourself?
Just because you think it's right
because all the fucking Elon Musks
and Shmelon Musks can be
on bucks are telling you.
Your dad told you so.
You read one book and you
fucking thought it was cool.
You want as much money as
possible to hook up with,
people because you're gonna
use the money to like hook up.
I don't know why.
But you need to realize that scale,
when you have this little
experience is fucking dangerous.
- So it's all about that macro patience
you always talk about.
- But working 17 hours a day,
bleeding out if you're
that fucking ambitious
and it makes you that happy.
So that micro speed that macro patience.
- It's my most important
framework because if you're happy,
and you know a lot of people don't micro,
they burn themselves out
because they actually don't like it,
they just want the money.
Yeah.
You know the scale, the money,
the win the cover of
Entrepreneur Magazine,
those are all the poisons, it's cliche.
It's true as fuck, I've watched it
for the last 20 years.
I've seen so many of my friends
look like they were winning
raise a ton of capital.
Fucking be the dominators
at South by Southwest
and 40 years later be out of a job.
I've just I've seen this rodeo, bro.
I lived it when you were born.
So like, I watched it.
I don't want you to put
scale on a pedestal.
I want you to put a
foundation on the pedestal.
- I see what you're saying.
So I don't wanna take
them much of your time,
but--
- It's okay.
So I listen to Tony Robbins,
I've gone to one of his seminars,
and he talks a lot about
winter is my season.
So how do we leverage, the the environment
that we're living in right now?
Per se--
- I apologize.
What does that mean?
Does that mean the tough
times is a good time?
- Yeah, the tough time is a good time.
- First of all,
you got really lucky because
a lot of people who are 30,
who did over leveraged
themselves never saw tough times
from 20 to 30.
And they didn't realize they existed.
I mean, people are
getting slayed right now.
It's kind of hidden right now.
'Cause there's still some bailouts.
We're not back to real life.
But I'm telling you right now, bro,
some of those coolest people on Instagram
and on the internet are going to be real,
real, real, real quiet
in December in February,
in next March, a year from
today, because people are out.
It's not just J crew.
Yes Dustin.
- It's just happening again.
Yeah, no worries.
So, I think that for you,
I don't think you can,
taking advantage of this time
requires liquid, if you
want to do it financially.
So people are sending a ton of cash,
are gonna buy up shit cheap.
Or it's gonna require realizing
this is a great moment
to foundationally teach you
that getting over leveraged
'cause you valued scale
over fundamentals is something
you don't want to do.
- Make sense.
Make sense.
- Awesome.
- That's all I have for you today.
Thank you.
I appreciate the help.
- Since I'm not going
to get to another one,
I'm gonna talk to Dustin
let me keep you here
for one more second.
Any insight to why you want scale?
- I'm not desperate for scale right now.
I guess maybe I didn't communicate that
'cause I know I'm young, I'm 20 years old.
I'm a sophomore in college.
I have no need to be the
biggest, real estate company--
- So its more out of
curiosity of how to do it?
Yeah, it's more out of I got
the opportunity to talk to you.
I wanna see--
- You know what the funny answer is?
It's still the same answer.
I'm gonna build the biggest
fucking scale of all time.
And I worked in a liquor
store when I was 32.
- Yeah, I see what you're saying.
It makes sense.
- Yeah, because, to me, it's
just like, people are confused
and how long this game is?
I'm 24 years older than you.
You were negative fucking four.
Like when I was your age, you
were negative fucking four.
- I've got time.
I've got time.
- No, no no, no.
You have.
Think of in a sporting analogy.
You haven't even woke up from your bed
and drove to the stadium yet,
you're still fucking sleeping in your bed
the day of the game.
Once you actually, I believe
the single biggest strength
I have is my relationship with time.
Because once you have that
relationship with time,
all the shit
that comes out of my mouth
makes a lot more sense.
If you actually understood
that you were going to live
for 100 more years
then you will fucking
really start thinking
about shit differently
and you won't make the moves
of the cliche 27 year old
that's got it like that.
There's been a lot of Alains,
that have lost because
they have it like that
or circumstance worked out
with family, they themselves have it.
And they got confident between 20 and 27.
And then they went in for
the kill, and it killed them.
I know all those guys.
And difference between those guys and me
and others is that patience.
And then when you know you know,
I put all my liquid assets into
focus Facebook, all of them.
If Facebook flopped, I would have zero.
But it was written there was no risk.
I was too experienced at the time.
That was already 10 years into my game.
I'd seen email.
I'd seen fucking Google AdWords.
I'd seen YouTube my space
friends like I seen it.
I met Zucks
I hung for a year and a half.
I watched the executives.
I knew Buzz.
I fucking knew Dave Morin.
I knew the culture.
I knew the product I watched.
I looked at the math.
I wasn't guessing.
I wasn't thinking in theory.
I was relying on experience.
Then I struck like a fucking cobra.
Got it?
- I got it.
- You will have 30 moments.
And it's like this is my moment.
If you're good enough, you'll
have 30 fucking moments.
- I appreciate it.
- Got you.
- That is the show today.
Sorry about the, video fucked up?
- Yeah it just coming in a little blurry
but it wasn't like cutting in and out
or anything it was just blurry.
- How about when I said
fucking struck like a cobra
- Yeah, I think it was blurry.
Still blurry right now, one second.
- You know what's not blurry?
winetex.com.
- That's true.
$65 red for 20 fucking $8 today Dustin.
Please sign up
for wine Tex calm It is
literally the single best service
of all time.
See ya.
I realize a lot of you
that watch Tea with Gary
Vee aren't signed up
for my podcast that makes me sad.
Here's what you're missing out on.
- You've helped me so much.
- Thank you bro.
- Navigating, it's all mindset.
When I entered college
I had such a bad mindset.
Because I was like,
"I don't really want to be here.
"I just wanna work."
But listening to the podcast
everyday having like,
positivity in my ears, has
really helped me along.
- Gary, if the mindset has been skewed,
how can you bring it back?
And I answered with by
surrounding yourself
with people who have the
mindset you aspire to.
Mold and I mean mold your
mindset, by what you consume,
and with whom you consume.
If you think your life is
shit, your life is shit.
Keep listening to more of my content,
you need fucking positivity
coming through your ears,
when fucking all that
negativity's coming your head.
Put your fucking headphones
in and listen to positivity.
If you can't move out yet,
put shit in your ears.
You walk in, put the fucking
headphones on in your house,
close your door and fucking listen.
You can listen while you're driving.
You can listen while you're traveling.
You can listen while you're working out.
You can listen while
you're walking the dog.
Find your shit.
Don't listen to the fucking the people
that shit on you, get in your own head,
put positivity around you.
Drop loser friends.
That negativity that you're hearing,
you got to get the fuck out of your life.
You need to put your fucking ear pods in.
and listen to positivity 24/7,
to get through that shit.
You understand?
When your surroundings are shit,
your insides got to be positive.
The fact that you're even here
means you're fucking halfway home.
(gentle music)